welcome back to sunday night in america
this evening we wanted to hear from you
from america
so we asked for your questions questions
about washington
the direction of our country how where
it's headed
whatever is on your mind but this is our
first time
it won't be our last but it's the first
together we are
working toward that more perfect
union our first question is from michael
from chicago
i'm assuming most people go into
congress
with a set of ideals of making
compromises and compromises what made
our nation great
it seems we're not doing that anymore
how do we get back to that
it is true our country has a rich
history of compromise the fact that each
state has two senators was a compromise
the electoral college was a compromise
some of those compromises were good and
some very much were not
it is true there are members now who are
more than willing to compromise to get
things done
but not on the big items i think that's
true for at least two reasons
people are worried about getting a
primary opponent and compromise is more
of a general election issue than a
primary issue
number two the differences seem pretty
stark right now
in terms of political ideology and
there's a belief among
some that the issue is better than the
solution
and by that i mean there's a reluctance
to give the other side any legislative
victories
at all look no further than last summer
there were enough votes to pass
tim scott's police reform bill but they
were not going to let him have a
legislative victory period
when will that change we can make a
change
the question is when we're working
together in terms of
priority in terms of how you vote
right now you can have a long and very
successful career in politics without
ever working with the other side our
next question comes from todd from
florida
term limits is that something that's
good to have new
people fresh ideas
obviously i believe in them because i
term limited myself i left i wasn't
i wasn't going to lose i didn't leave to
run for something else i just left
so when i hear term limits i think term
limits on public service not just
limits on one office or another and
here's why i say that
if you limit members of the house to
three terms
nothing will change if they're just
going to wind up running for the u.s
senate or governor
or attorney general the purpose of term
limits is to
in theory free the person to vote
without an eye toward
personal ambition if there is always
another office to run for there will
always be the temptation
to vote for what is in your best
interest and not the best interest of
the whole
ambition is incredibly powerful if you
want to curb political ambition
you have to curb their time in politics
not just a single office our final
question comes from grant boone
who emailed asking as a prosecutor how
do you withstand the emotional
toll that the substance of a case takes
on you
how can those of us aspiring lawyers
handle the burden of darkness
that a lawyer encounters in their work
i did not withstand it i lost that
battle when all you see is depravity you
begin to believe
that it is all that exists so i am
probably not the best person to help you
separate uh work from the rest of life
because i was not able
to do so the best prosecutors are the
ones who can communicate the pain the
heartache the loss the criminality of
what happened
and do it in a persuasive way and to
communicate it effectively you have to
feel it
and to feel it it changes you
so you have three options really you can
do it for a little while
and then stop you can do it but have
some source of
light in your life your faith your
spouse your children
something that can temper the darkness
or unfortunately
you can just surrender and live life as
a cynic
it's the best job you will ever have
just understand
it is more than a job and it does take
over other aspects
of your life if you have a question for
us you can find us on social media
at gowdy america hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else